[Applause]
blade Smiths welcome to the forge there
will be no signature blades in your
signature style today instead you'll be
making this Weapon made famous by the
United States Marine Corps
that is the iconic k-bar
since World War II the k-bar has been
the fighting knife of the United States
Marine Corps featuring a short
lightweight blade a clip point the
weapon is famous for its multitude of
uses from Close Quarters combat to
chopping wood to even opening cans it is
the trusted sidearm for Devil Dogs and
survivalists alike
let's talk a little bit about what
you're making these K bars out of today
you'll be working with this
[Music]
no Globe all anchor the crossbarrel is
W1 high carbon steel the anchor shape is
mild steel you'll have to harvest that
hardenable and Mild steel to use in your
blades and utilize a sand my technique
good luck your three hour Starts Now
we're gonna attack this anchor as we
would any combat mission
[Music]
hold on to it from the other side once
the Marine always the Marine always
start to work as a team
I gotta borrow a partnerable steel I
flattened it out stick it between my two
pieces of mild steel and uh tossing his
boards get it welded this initial press
is what's going to make or break me
being able to make a sand my knife
start going at it immediately I can tell
that I got a good weld I think I'm good
to go
my game plan for this is I don't want
any mild steel down near my Edge or my
bevels so I'm going to use two Thin
strips of mild steel one on each side my
heart it will still miss the jacketed
and we'll Forge weld that together that
will have meat parameters and the spine
is strong and the knife is still really
tough
I draw my three pieces of metal out and
I realized my two pieces of mild steel
they're not as long as the hard W1 steel
I got it on a thick centerpiece those
lean pieces of mild heat up faster and
cool quicker don't necessarily weld very
well I'm running out of time so I'm
going to the press to do my Forge weld I
know that that weld is a critical point
if you get delaminations or that well
doesn't stick you're going to be in
trouble
she ain't gonna be pretty
trips in the quench
pulled out of the quench I see a small
warp but I believe I can grind it out
that will work just fine
[Music]
I get my blade shaped and now I'm
thinking about heat treating it
I take it out and it seems nice and
straight to me
so feeling pretty good
Garrett just wished
pull it out and I've got just a little
wiggle in it so I head over to my jig
give it a good twist
warp seems to come right out I think
Garrett's really showing some some
really smart scientific work
five four three two one place this shut
down your machines drop your tools this
round of competition is over
[Applause]
here Marines welcome to the rifle chop
to test the strength and durability of
your blades as well as the overall
construction of your k-bars I will be
chopping mercilessly into these rifles
trip you're on first you ready I've had
a killer all right
this cable it looks badass but hey there
could be a fracture or something in my
blade that thing could pop go across the
shop and kill somebody
[Music]
holy crap
my trip nice job there is glinting here
and up here towards the tip but this
held up phenomenally well overall thank
you all right Jean you're up you ready
giddy up all right
just the way he swings that thing into
that rifle it's insane no knife should
be able to handle that and I can't
believe that uh he's gonna do it to mine
nice
[Music]
hear that sound yep that's your guard
yep your guard is now loose can't tell
if the handle slipped back from it but
there's a big gap there in this motion
overall though it's all in one piece so
well done thank you come on Garrett
you've seen what I'm gonna do oh God how
you feeling
yep all right
yep it is
this test is going to be the hardest
test I've ever done on any of my blades
I'm afraid that that pommel is just
gonna come right off and that's what's
going to send me home
thank you
because I the only one that seen a spark
that was crazy well Garrett there is a
decent chunk out of your blade right
here
this is the site of two impacts at least
and it lost you know there's a piece of
your blade still over there somewhere
the rest of your knife is still tight
still there it's all in one piece mostly
thank you
red Marines this is the sharpest test
today the fight is all about cutting
through these ropes except you're up
first you ready for this bro let's do it
[Music]
all right
so I feel like man I was on top of the
world a while ago and now I'm at the
down bottom of the barrel hoping not to
go home
all right trip I love the handle it
really marries into my hand when I put
it on but just the fact that I can do
this it's not very sharp at all it did
scratch and cut a little bit but not as
deeply as I thought it should
overall sir you're a bleed
kind of cuts
right Jean your turn sir you ready you
bet let's do this
[Music]
giddy up
nice all right you can talk about your
key bar here the edge you put on despite
having some glinting right here is still
Sharp took down all the ropes it feels
good when you're swinging it an overall
sir it'll cut yes there it is he said it
all right Garrett you're up next you
ready sir let's do it let's do it I feel
like I'm at a definite disadvantage
after trip snipe didn't go through any
of the ropes I need my knife to cut
through them or else I could be going
home
foreign
[Music]
the handles have been on the larger side
there's some extra space right there but
when you grab onto it it is comfortable
despite having a chip right here you can
see it still cuts cut on one of the
swings it actually got hung up on that
one section right there but it does cut
through the first rope and some of the
second rope and a little bit on the
third overall sir it'll cut thank you
all right blade Smiths the judges have
deliberated they've made their final
decision it's time for one of you
Marines to leave the forge the blade
Smith leaving the forge is
Garrett
your blade didn't make the cut Garrett
Above All Else the quality of a blade is
something an end user depends on while
this was very close we base our decision
that your blade did the most damage on
the strength test for that reason we're
sending yum I understand
Garrett please render your blade
my blade took the most damage it's only
fair that I go home
but I'm so glad that I had the
opportunity to compete and especially
with three other Marines talk about her
Brotherhood I would have loved to
represent the Marine Corps in the final
challenge but I got two great Smiths out
there that are going to do a great job